hi my name is Cece Regan and I am a
screenwriter I'm independent and I've
been writing since 2005 I have five
short films I have one book trailer I
have a music video and a webseries and I
currently have four feature films
completed but not produced yet and the
one I'm currently writing right now is
called to the president it is a sci-fi
drama why I decided to write this film
the idea came to me over two years ago
and I've always been in love with sci-fi
mystery anything that can make me
curious I want to go down the looking
glass and explore ideas that maybe we
haven't fully thought out yet
I love philosophy and religion and
archaeology in general anthropology so
screenwriting for me is something that
could combine all these fields together
and when the idea hit me
I was actually researching I think
that's one of my favorite parts of
screenwriting is to really throw myself
in and research the idea in concept and
I had never heard of telepathy being
created at a university level telepathy
in the sense that they were creating
classes in the 70s that were
workshopping these ideas in the
parapsychology department so when I
heard about that historical fact I knew
that there was something more and I
decided to go adventure out
research and find people that maybe were
a part of this establishment so that
concept alone is really mind-blowing and
it makes fiction not as freaky as
reality so those are the type of films
that I want to create I want to create
things that kind of make your mind Bend
and make you doubt things that have been
taught to your whole life that make you
think out of the box so that's why I
haven't given up on the script it has
really put me in a spot where I need to
make sure that nothing's cliche but at
the same time there's a light
heartedness where it's not so serious
where we could process it and maybe use
our imagination to really want to fall
into the concept in the storyline so far
my screenwriting career it it has
definitely been a journey and no matter
what all the boundaries and barriers
have come my way I've gotten so close to
meeting with that executive at the
studio but you know those those moments
were meant to happen so that I can be
here now and I'm really excited about
this I hope this is my future debut I
also would love to direct this piece as
well so I the biggest lesson I've
learned in screenwriting is that
everybody has a story and there's always
more than one side and until you've
lived in someone's shoes then you
clearly can't understand what choices
they make and that I believe has made me
a better person
I believe that screenwriting has allowed
me to unveil more compassion and
hopefully I put that into my characters
that more people understand different
types of people different types from
different countries different
backgrounds different class and that we
will all recognize at the end that we're
all from the same human race and love
each other more and so that's what I
want to bring to the table
as in my screenwriting career I want to
create that hope and that exploration of
ideas were science and mysticism meet
together so thank you and good night